قياده السياره بسرعه زائده سلوك يعاقب
عليه القانون دون ان ينهي بالضروره مسيره
سياسيه لوزير
لكن وزيره الداخليه البريطانيه
الحصول على معامله تفضيليه لتسويه
مخالفتها المروريه امر اغضب بعض زملائها
وكل خصومها السياسيين
عادي كنت اقود بسرعه وانا نادمه على ذلك
لقد دفعت المخالفه وقابلت العقوبه لم اسعى
الى التهرب ابدا لكن دعونا نكون صادقين
بان المعارضه تريد تشتيت الانتباه عن
فشلها
يبدو ان هناك قانونا لوزراء الحكومه
وقانونا ثانيا للاخرين الى متى سننتظر حتى
يفتح تحقيق
تحقيق تطالب به احزاب المعارضه لكن رئيس
الوزراء ريشيسونيك يتجنب الامر بفتحه
فوزيره الداخليه براي مراقبي حليفته
الوثيقه التي تضمن له ولا التيار اليميني
في حزبه وتعمل على تطبيق سياسته المرجوه
بترحيل طالبي اللجوء القادمين عبر البحر
طالما تعاملت الوزيره مع القضيه بالطريقه
الملائمه ودفعت المخالفه فالامر اصبح
مبالغا فيه ليغطي على القضايا الحقيقيه
التي تواجهنا
نعم هي مجرد مواطنه عاديه ويجب التعامل
معها على هذا الاساس يجب التحقيق معها
وتوبيخها ان اتضح ان هناك داعيا لذلك
لم تمر اسابيع على استقاله نائب رئيس
الوزراء بعدما خلص تحقيق مستقل الى انه
تنمر على موظفيه وقبله وقيل رئيس حزب
المحافظين بسبب تهرب ضريبي فضائح لا يرغب
رئيس الوزراء بمزيد منها في حكومته تعهد
سوكا عندما تولى منصبه بحكومه تتحلى
بالنزاهه والكفاءه وتضع حدا لتجاوزات شابت
عمل الحكومه السابقه لكن الكشف الجديد
بشان وزيره الداخليه يدفع كثيرين الى
التساؤل عن مدى جديته وما اذا كان يحابي
بعض اجنحه حزبه على حساب تنفيذ المسائله
التي وعد بها محمد المدهون الجزيره لندن